the question we've been hearing a lot
lately about computer science and being
a software developer is should I go to
school or not is it worth it to get a
bachelor's degree or a master's degree
or PhD in computer science a lot of
people are wondering this do I go to
university to get a job or do I just do
it well the short answer is you just do
it I've been at school for a good four
years straight and I've changed a lot in
this four years it's been very
beneficial to me I think school is worth
it if you're having a little trouble
with motivation or direction if you have
motivation already and if you have
direction already you don't really need
school that badly because you're already
going out and getting the experience you
need school is basically to help you get
experience another thing that tends to
have from a school that doesn't happen
so much in the real world is and school
you end up taking a lot of time and just
like reading and going to lectures and
kind of just kind of sitting there and
not actually a whole lot of doing
usually what tends to happen that gets
you doing is suddenly the teacher
assigned something and gives it a
deadline for what it's due and that gets
you going and motivated to do research
on your own and figure out the problem
and if you do take the time to do
research on your own and figure out
these problems you will learn a lot a
lot but you won't learn much from going
to the lectures and you won't learn much
from reading the assigned stuff it's
from doing the actual projects at least
this is how it was for me what this has
led me to believe is that if you just
already have the motivation and are
already doing projects and it's working
for you you don't need to pay thousands
of dollars a semester to go to school
just to sit in the lectures and read the
assigned stuff main thing that get
actually gets you learn as projects if
you're giving yourself projects that's
great there's also tons of stuff online
tons of tutorials online I think school
is gonna be very useless in like ten
years really soon the internet and just
the plethora of data out there on
anything you want to research
it's pretty amazing people that realize
these things I've said will not continue
out of schools it's just a waste of
money you can be out earning money and
learning your trade at the same time I
think that's very true with computer
science there are some stipulations here
computer science it's not the easiest
thing and when I say computer science
I'm saying that because I'm in
specifically a CS degree and I'm talking
swiftly about the CS degree but most
software developers don't align with
computer science most of them are web
developers they design and style things
and only use basic math when you get
into computer science you learn about
the architecture of computers and chips
and motherboards and how things really
work and how how different chips and
devices considered delays and and
there's a lot of details that go into it
it is literally the science of computers
it's not about software development
software development plays a big part of
it but as a whole computer science is
more about solving the problems of
computing and designing actual computers
and of course the software is on top of
all that so it gets into a lot of math a
lot of theory and a lot of hardware and
most most college degrees that do
computer science require a lot of math
and a lot of additional sciences and
these are pretty useless for software
development almost entirely
[Music]
the classes I have enjoyed are the ones
that gave me programming projects every
time and in my own time in the during
the summer when I had no school I did my
own projects I just decided things I
wanted to do and started to create them
it was really going to school that
introduced me to a lot of the things I
needed to get started I didn't know
where to start so that's why it's been
really really useful for me but at the
same time now they've gone through and a
lot of research I see why it could be
useless to some people as well if you
have any questions let me know I hope
you have a good day and thanks for
watching my video peace out
you
[Music]
you